comme chaque année les aficionados de la
mode attendent ce moment avec impatience
les soldes d'hiver débutent ce mercredi
20 janvier en france on va être
l'assistant du matin carrément où les
prix baissent c'est toujours intéressant
moi ça me tente mais bon après voilà il
faut que les finances suivent cette
année le contexte sanitaire va
bouleverser le mode de fonctionnement
des magasins ce sera le cas dans cette
boutique de 110 m² implantés à plaisir
ici et les horaires seront adaptés pour
respecter le couvre-feu à 18 heures
cette décision pourrait avoir un impact
sur les ventes fermer des magasins 17h30
alors qu'on les ferme à 20h en règle
générale en moyenne il est certain que
pour le textile spécial spécifiquement
pour nous
c'est ce créneau horaire va être avoir
une grosse incidence non moi je pense
qu'on sera entre je pense qu'on va
perdre entre 30 et 40% du chiffre
enfin vous cacher qu'on n'est pas on
n'est pas serein par rapport à ça à
monti le bretonneux cette boutique doit
également modifier ses habitudes
aucun cdd elle a été créée pour la
période des soldes dès les premiers
jours les décotes seront plus
importantes pour atteindre les prix
d'une deuxième démarque
enfin les stocks sont également moins
important par rapport aux années
précédentes
nous avons une table importants mobile
et un petit murale très léger bon ça
veut dire qu'elle peut aller que ça
diminue ça diminue ça diminue mais là
avec la conjoncture et les locaux vides
forcément les stocks sont encore moins
important les soldes d'hiver se
termineront le 16 février prochain les
français devraient dépenser en moyenne
près de 319 euros lors de ce rendez vous